bar is saying this much simon comes up  just resign yeah just get it done with  dude i thought he was going to let his  clock run out he went down to two  seconds there and now pride can even go  three pawns up and he's just gonna take  this pawn he's gonna go back for white's  remaining a porn and dude has had enough  yeah  mike's still so focused though oh he's  still going he's still going he's gonna  be only three pawns down  just resign dada come on  but i mean look at prague  i mean i'm so in awe like most people  here would be relaxing i would be  breathing out heavily  the job is done the hard work is done  but he's still so focused and dude i  can't even look at the screen you know  he's that disgusted with his position  there's just no hope whatsoever and he's  just going through the motions until he  just  works up  that will to resign  yeah he's getting himself ready  psychologically for tie breaks and there  we go  it's over prague in a must-win situation  he takes